[Music]
[Applause]
uh Booger McFarland of the mothership
the football analyst he is uh there
covering college football on site last
night for the national title game with
Michigan and Washington uh booger thanks
for joining us your takeaway from this
game is
what Michigan was clearly the better
football team it was a Lon of scrimmage
game last night and um you know there
was a a Super Bowl I can't remember
which one it was a few years ago when
Seattle played Denver and everybody
started to think that man maybe just
maybe really good offense had started to
take over and you could dominate a game
with really good offense and what
happened we saw the Seattle Seahawks
dominate the Broncos and I get the game
was in New York the weather was uh less
than ideal uh but really good defense
dominated that game and we came into
this game Dan saying that man how is
Michigan going to deal with Michael
pennick and his accuracy and these three
wide receivers all are who going to play
in the NFL last night was another subtle
reminder that really good defense beats
really good offense and it was a
professional defense you know Jim
Harbaugh made a change a few years ago
when he went away from Don Brown the
longtime Michigan defensive coordinator
and he got into this Baltimore Ravens
tree of Defense it was Mike McDonald
Mike McDonald went back to Baltimore he
got Jesse Mentor but it was essentially
the same system and he did it to beat
Ohio State well lo and behold Ohio state
was very similar to Washington great
quarterback great athletes three wide
receivers and really good defense
dominated the game last night and
Michigan rushed for 300 yards and they
dominated uh the trenches but the single
biggest key in the game last night was
Michigan's defense and not what they did
this year but the change that Harbaugh
made several years ago going from Don
Brown to this Baltimore Raven style of
defense and that style is the number one
defense in pro football and it's the
number one defense in college football
look at these quarterbacks going
forward U Michael penx Jr JJ
McCarthy going forward I think you have
to factor in a lot of things number one
age penic 6 23 he's got a history of
injuries two ACLS shoulder surgery
dislocated shoulder uh JJ McCarthy has
been really inconsistent he doesn't wue
with the numbers but he is athletic he
can move and we see that that's where
the game is going these days I think the
number one attribute a quarterback must
have Dan is the ability to be accurate
and throw the football where you needed
to be Michael pennick does that as good
as anybody that's going to be in this
coming draft um but the knocks against
him are what I stated earlier with the
the age and the injuries JJ
McCarthy I'm not really sure he's
consistent enough uh last night he
didn't show us anything to change that
he only made two or three throws that
would that you would deem game-changing
throws or throws that you will remember
last night so going forward I still
would rather have Michael penck Jr I
don't know if he'll be a top 15 or top
20 pick hell I don't know if he'll be a
first round pick but I do know the one
thing he does better than anybody else
is store the football accurately and
let's not take last night as a
referendum on Michael pennick he was
under immense pressure last night and it
wouldn't have mattered if it was Joe
Montana or Patrick Mahomes last night I
think Washington would have had the same
fate because of the pressure and the
defense that he faced last night yeah I
thought Michigan did a wonderful job of
disguising where that pressure was
coming from and I thought that you know
penck couldn't get comfortable he had a
couple of you know wide openen receivers
couple of moments there where it thought
I thought that they could maybe make it
a little bit more of an interesting game
uh Jim Harbaugh if you're Jim Harbaugh
what would you do let's say you have
opportunities in the NFL but what would
you do if you're Jim
Harbaugh I think I have to explore those
opportunities a little deeper and ask
the questions like the reason Jim
Harbaugh I think is fascinated with the
NFL is because he has unfinished
business there but let's re let's go
backwards to the last time he was in the
National Football League he was with the
49ers Trent baly was the GM I don't
think the relationship was great with
balky and so they kind of buted heads a
lot and so now you fast forward and
bring us to the present day if he does
get back in the NFL Dan I think it's got
to be the right situation meaning he's
got to have total control now what does
that mean it doesn't mean he's the head
coach in GM it simply means he's the
head coach and the guy that is his GM is
either somebody he picks or somebody
that is that is on the same page as him
kind of like Kyle Shanahan John Lynch
like those guys work together they were
hired at the same time their contracts
are concurrent so you know that they are
in this thing together and they see
football the same way well can Jim
Harbaugh find find a situ ation whether
it's the Chargers the Raiders the
Falcons the Panthers can he find a
situation that is that an owner that a
billionaire owner and you'll get this
better than better than I do a
billionaire owner is ready to seed
control of his tire organ entire
organization to Jim Harbaugh and said GM
I don't know if there's a situation like
that would the Spanos family do it I
don't know they seem to really want to
be handson would would terer do it I
don't know he seems to be really hands
on so like if you think about the think
about the openings is there anybody
that's going to give him total control
because I believe that's what he wants
and if he doesn't get total control I
think he's going back to
Michigan does Harbaugh's raah ra style
still work in the
NFL Harbaugh is a leader of men that
works in any company whether it's the
NFL whether it's television whether it's
Bank of America when you understand how
to lead and Galvanize people D it work
works it doesn't matter the style and
which you do it in what matters is can
you relate and can you connect with your
employees that is the essential thing
that matters and yeah it was different
back then like that NFL is different
than the NFL now but guess what did you
watch the Michigan football team last
night those are basically young NFL
players like it's a lot of seniors and
juniors on their team and so you're
talking about really not but three or
four years removed from the median age
in the National Football League now so I
I would I I would be guessed to say that
the average age of every team right now
is probably 26 27 well the team he was
coaching last night the average age was
probably 21 like those it's a senior
Laden team so he got those guys to run
through a wall not only did he do that
he got a lot of those guys to come back
and play another year rather than going
to the National Football League and so
to answer your question directly I think
his style still works because he is a
great leader of men and that Works in
any company talking to Booger McFarland
of the mothership he was at the national
title game with Michigan in Washington
if you ran the Bears you would do
what I
would keep Justin Fields I would pick up
the fifth year option and so I would
continue to take a look at him year four
year five so I have two more years to
look at him I would tell him this I
would say I want you to succeed we're
going to pick up your 50 your option
we're not going to extend you long term
just yet we're going to surround you
with every weapon that we can and we're
going to build this football team in the
mindset that you are the quarterback
going forward I need you to go out and
prove me right and when you do not if
but when you do then we will discuss the
long-term deal I can't give you five
years and 250 million now though because
I need to see more and fortunately for
me I have an Avenue in which I can go
down that is kind of a kind of an kind
of an olive branch so I'll extend the
olive branch which is the fifth your
option I'm not going to cut you I'm not
going to trade you but I'm going to
extend the Olive Branch are you willing
to play on the fifth year option while I
build this team around you and continue
to progress if he's willing to do that
uh then that's the route I go if he says
that I just can't do it then I'm gonna
move on and so I think it has to be a
partnership not a dictatorship meaning I
have to go to Justin fields and his
represent it is and we have to get be in
this together because I don't want him
coming in the locker room for the next
two years unhappy worried about his
contract like we need to be on the same
page so that's how I would approach it
if you ran the
Patriots if I ran the Patriots I would
really simply say this like sometimes um
we all wear our welcome out at some
point Andy Reid great coach it was time
for him to Le Philadelphia he's had a
ton of success in Kansas City doesn't
mean you're a bad coach and I would just
simply say say this to Bill like we've
done a lot of good things together but I
would like to try on a new pair of shoes
like there's this new this new thing
that came out called the iPhone like I
want to go away from the flip phone and
go to the iPhone nothing against the
flip phone it did me well but I want to
go to this new invention called the
iPhone and I'm willing to allow you to
move on and I think if if you're Bill
there would be opportunities out there
and I would do that sooner than later so
Bill can have his choice of all the
opportunities that are open so I would
do this this week so before Friday I
would have a conversation with Bill and
simply say this I'm going to move on um
I'm willing to do whatever it is that I
can to help you in your next situation
is that a trade is that just a full on
out release I'm not I don't want to fire
you do you want me to fire you whatever
Bill wants me to do to help him as we
move forward I would do because I
respect him that much I'm I I wouldn't
say hey I'm firing bill I would just say
we decided to mutually part in move ways
so we can try different things but I I I
do think it's time because everybody
needs to change a scenery at some point
I mean hell Dan you've upgraded your
facility at some point like you've
gotten a do even though you've been
doing this for a long time we all need
to kind of upgrade and renovate every
now and then good to talk to you booger
safe travels thanks for joining us as
always always man always enjoyed talking
to you it's a very pleasant conversation
that's Booger McFarland ESPN NFL college
football analyst and uh won a couple of
Super Bowls he's very good